A coffee filter’s job is pretty simple -
hold back the large, bitter grounds,
and let the liquid coffee through.
Scientists have now invented a new technique
that flips the script, holding back small
particles but letting larger ones pass.
Instead of sorting particles by size,
this reverse filter sorts them by kinetic energy --
larger, heavier objects with more force
break through the barrier,
while lighter, slower objects don’t.
Inspired by the process of phagocytosis --
when our cells swallow foreign objects --
the barrier itself is made of a self-healing liquid,
similar to a cell membrane.
To make the magical membrane,
researchers need only a metal ring and two ingredients:
deionized water and sodium dodecyl sulfate (SDS),
a compound commonly used in laundry detergent.
When researchers tested their filter,
they found it could be repeatedly penetrated without
rupturing, even after 3 hours of constant prodding.
It could also hold back gas
while letting bigger objects through
and even kept the lid
on a beaker full of scrambling fruit flies.
And by varying the concentration of SDS,
scientists could finely tune the surface tension of the
membrane-- the key to its remarkable abilities.
At very high levels of tension, only the larger or
faster-moving particles make it through
before the liquid seals together again.
But at low levels of tension, smaller, or
slower-moving particles can do the same thing.
That means scientists could use it in a variety of ways:
as a surgical membrane that blocks
out dust and germs,
a barrier against infection-transmitting insects,
or even as a thin film that could
trap odors in a waterless toilet.
What’s more, the membrane is self-cleaning:
Small, trapped particles are easily transported
across its slanting surface and off to the side,
keeping the membrane free of contaminants.
The resulting filter may make for
more successful surgeries and better odor eaters.
But if you want the perfect cup of joe,
you might want to stick to an old-fashioned filter.